la russie entretient l'idée d'une
troisième guerre mondiale elle affirme
que l'ukraine a frappé sur son sol
plusieurs explosions ont été entendues
dans trois régions russes proche de la
frontière avec l'ukraine les autorités
rapportent aussi un incendie dans un
dépôt de munitions à belgorod ce qui est
certain c'est que la guerre a vraiment
lieu en ukraine depuis 63 jours les
russes sont accusées de nombreux crimes
de guerre et de massacres bonjour
gulliver crack vous êtes l'envoyé
spécial de france 24 à bout de chasse et
près de la capitale où 50 cadavres ont
été découverts dans cette ville après le
départ des forces russes début avril
quelle est la situation aujourd'hui
50 en fait c'est le chiffre donné par
les nations unies les autorités locales
abuja parle de plus de 400 cadavres en
fait qui ont été trouvées je pense que
les nations unies ont donc été
uniquement sur un seul endroit
actuellement je me trouve devant la
mangue de boudhha est latente que vous
voyez derrière moi c'est une tante qui
fait office de centre d'information pour
les citoyens qui viennent chercher leurs
proches ou les corps de leurs proches je
parlais tout à l'heure à l'employé de la
mairie qui se charge de 7 ans et elle
dit que la plupart des gens qui viennent
et ils sont des dizaines tous les jours
savent que leurs proches sont morts mais
ne savent pas où les corps se trouvent
tous les corps n'ont pas pu être placés
dans cette manche ici donc ils sont
dispersés à différentes sans droits elle
les aide à trouver les corps mais il y a
aussi des gens qui viennent pour qui les
prochains ont tout simplement disparu
ils ne savent pas s'ils sont en vie ou
s'ils sont décédés donc la mairie essaye
tant bien que mal à les aider à trouver
ce qui est arrivé à leurs proches et
cette employée de la mairie m'a dit
qu'elle même était partie au tout début
de l'invasion elle s'est enfuie mais
elle est revenue il y a deux semaines
mais vit pour le moment haïr pin à côté
de boudhha dans une maison où il n'y a
pas d'électricité ni des gaz mais elle
m'a dit que tout va bien parce qu'ils
ont une cheminée dont la maison ce qui
permet de cuisiner à d'autres endroits
de bouddha et dire pin l'électricité est
déjà revenu c'est le cas des immeubles
que vous voyez derrière moi
il y à déjà l'électricité de nombreuses
familles sont déjà venus il y a même des
enfants qui jouent dans la cour donc
petit à petit malgré la tragédie qui est
arrivé dans cette ville la vie revient
du liver je profite de votre présence
pour faire un point sur le reste du pays
notamment dans le sud de l'ukraine les
russes affirment
contrôler toute la région de kherson est
ce que les ukrainiens le confirme
également ou pas
non les ukrainiennes ne confirme pas que
les russes contrôlent toute la région
des personnes mais je pense que les
russes contrôlent la plupart de cette
région et surtout sa capitale la ville
des personnes qui est la seule grande
ville de l'est la russie a est arrivé à
apprendre depuis le début de l'invasion
hier les russes ont mis en place un
maire qui l'ont choisi aon et ce matin
certains habitants de la ville ont tenté
de manifester contre cette décision mais
les manifestations a été très vite
dispersés par les russes à coups de gaz
lacrymogènes et les forces russes ont
même fait quelques blessés il est
difficile d'avoir des informations
venant des personnes parce que les gens
ont peur de parler mais l'image globale
qu'on a c'est que toute tentative de
protester contre l'occupation russe est
très sévèrement réprimée il y à de
nombreux cas de personnes qui ont été
faits prisonniers et tabassés par les
forces russes et de nombreuses personnes
aussi qui sont portées disparues par
leurs proches merci beaucoup pour ces
éléments gulliver craag